hey guys I'm back in this video we're
gonna talk about xylitol I actually like
xylitol because it's there's no
aftertaste it tastes very close to sugar
but let's kind of cover some key points
about this okay so it can actually
reduce tooth decay and has a glycemic
index of around 7 sometimes some
references say it's up to 30 so it's on
the low side so it can affect blood
sugars a little bit especially in in
greater quantities okay so if you're
consuming a large quantities it can also
give you gas and digestive issues but
you'd have to consume something like 50
or 65 grams of it but if you have small
amounts it should be fine
it's fatal and dogs so you this is very
serious you want to actually keep it
away from your dog and I keep it on a
high shelf and make sure that there's no
way my dog is going to be exposed to
that it's been used for nasal spray
because it's it helps the bacteria not
adhere to the wall of your mucous
membranes so it kind of clears out
microbes now the real key thing with the
xylitol is where it comes from birch
bark is a really good source but you
want to make sure you get it non-gmo
xylitol because they can make a wreath
throat all from GMO corn and you don't
want to consume that because it's been
exposed to glyphosate which is an
herbicide so just get the one that says
organic or non-gmo because if it is
organic it's going to be non-gmo alright
thanks for watching
hey guys so I'm doing a survey of a
future video and I wanted to find out
what your biggest body problem is so
that way the content is aligning with
something that you are personally
interested in so please click the link
down below fill it out and I will create
the video thanks